[Music]
20:17 has been home to a bunch of
platformers inspired by a very special
era of games a hat and time poi and
ukulele have all had their time to shine
and there's this thing called super
mario odyssey releasing very soon maybe
you've heard of it but these games all
have one thing in common they take cues
from the platforming greats of the
Nintendo 64 so we're gonna count down
the top 9 platformers from Nintendo's
rad retro console some of these are
no-brainers some might surprise you and
others you might not even remember but
it all starts with number 9 Space
Station Silicon Valley DMA design is
better known today as Rockstar North yes
this cutesy platformer is from the same
team that went on to create the
blockbuster Grand Theft Auto series but
before players took control of Niko
Bellic or Trevor Phillips they
controlled a robot who crash-landed on a
space station more accurately they
control the robots little microchip
which could be used to jack into various
animals to complete levels across the
stations for different environments some
animals were faster some were stronger
but you had to use the whole zoo if you
wanted to get through this one number 8
spider-man spider-man is the only
licensed game you'll find on this list
and it absolutely earns its place for
the first time Spidey fans could swing
crawl and beat up bad guys in an open 3d
environment the comic-book vibe is
definitely here in spades too each level
is an issue of the spider-man comic
series with some sweet cover art in
loading screens and as far as villains
there are oh so many to fight here if
you're a fan of the multiverse Spidey's
like spider-man 2099 or The Scarlet
Spider you'll be happy to know that you
can unlock plenty of alternate costumes
for the webslinger too number 7 go
Iman's great adventure and now we get to
talk about our only 2.5 D choice after
going full 3d two years before the
mystical ninja series went back to the x
and y-axes with gell-mann's great
adventure but the levels still have much
to explore with multiple paths and even
side quests to complete as you make your
way from left to right
you can even go on the
sure with a friend in co-op mode and you
might need the help since the game's
day/night cycle brings out faster and
tougher enemies once the Sun Goes Down
number six
jet force Gemini this is the first game
from developer rare on this list but you
can be sure it's not the last jet force
Gemini is part platformer part shooter
fusing together elements of earlier rare
games like banjo-kazooie and Goldeneye
the Gemini team has to take down the
evil insectoid Mizar a mission that
involves multiple planets and nonlinear
levels across the galaxy having a trio
of heroes on the team also means
switching up control and using special
powers to breathe underwater or cross
lava and of course it wouldn't be a
platformer shooter hybrid without some
multiplayer deathmatches number 5
Conker's Bad Fur Day I'm sure you've
noticed that this list has been very kid
friendly but Conker's Bad Fur Day is
absolutely not that rare went a very
different direction from its other games
here at least thematically sure it's a
platformer at heart but conker drinks
heavily pees on fires and helps bees and
bucks and flowers get busy leaning back
on the shooter mechanics of jet force
Gemini it also offers a pretty lengthy
shooting segment that pokes fun at
Saving Private Ryan and of course that's
just one of many many parodies conker
offers I mean the final boss is a
combination of alien and Super Mario
64's Bowser fights number 4 banjo tooie
it might be weird to talk about the
sequel first but don't worry we'll get
to banjo kazooie soon the follow up
cranks the imagination of the first game
up to 11 with levels like Hellfire Peaks
which is a split between a fire and an
icy side and cloud cuckoo-land a sky
level with a bunch of weird floating
islands and while a lot of 3d
platformers force you out to a hub world
in between levels banjo tooie
interconnected worlds are still
impressive to this day sometimes you
even have to find those secret passages
in order to collect everything the
burden bear also get a huge list of new
powers during the journey not to mention
a multiplayer mode featuring all the
minigames you'll encounter along the way
number three Donkey Kong 64 before
banjo-tooie
rare brought one of Nintendo's main
mascots into 3d with DK 64 along with
that came a totally redesigned DK island
and a handful of simply massive levels
too much for just Donkey Kong a Cocker
on his own
fortunately you also get to control
other members of DK's family Diddy tiny
lanky and chunky Kong and I think we
know who the standout is there and of
course each member of the family has
their own set of powers and items to
help you collect every delicious banana
but beyond all the big levels and
special abilities Donkey Kong 64 has
stayed in our hearts for one very hip
reason number 2 banjo kazooie told you
we'd get to it soon banjo kazooie was
rares very first platformer on the n64
and it's definitely where the magic
started the Baron Byrd's first adventure
is so much more than just a series of
jumps and collectables levels aren't
just about getting from A to B they're
packed with unique characters like mumbo
jumbo a shaman who transforms you into
some crazy creature or contraption in
every level and the further you go the
more complex the worlds become the final
stage click clock would requires you to
rotate the world through spring summer
fall and winter to access certain parts
of the level banjo kazooie's showed just
how elaborate 3d platformers could be
and number one super mario 64 before any
other game on this list came Super Mario
64 the Plummers first foray and the 3d
totally changed how we perceive his
world stars weren't invincibility
power-ups anymore they were the main
collectible and collecting coins wasn't
just for a high score they also filled
Mario's health bar between bomb on
battlefield shifting sand land and so
many other levels you'd be hard-pressed
to find a game with more memorable
stages not to mention a fully explorable
Peach's castle with secrets of its own
Mario 64 paved the
for every 3d platformer to come just
like Super Mario Brothers did for 2d
platformers on the NES and there you
have it our top and 64 platformers of
all time what did you think of our
choices what games would be on your own
list let me know in the comments below
and if you liked this look back at older
games consider checking out our history
of series where we dive into big
franchises like Sonic the Hedgehog and
Uncharted
[Music]